so as we continue our series on the road
to Civil War what I want to do here is
spend the next few days
running over Tony Stark's Iron Man
armors from the movies and what I'm
hoping is that much like my armor series
from the comics at the end of all this
you'll walk away with a better
understanding of the different types of
suits available to Tony Stark as well as
how each one functions to improve on
previous designs so beginning with the
mark 1 as it was seen in Iron Man 1 this
suit was really more of a primitive
design and serve the purpose of allowing
Tony Stark to escape imprisonment
alongside ho yinsen while yinsen was
killed in a conflict much like the mark
1 from the comics the mark 1 in the
movies was a precursor to the future
designs of Tony Stark regarding his Iron
Man suits in terms of his capabilities
because the suit was composed of parts
from existing storm weapons specifically
the Jericho missiles emulated artillery
the mark ones outer alloy is relatively
dense and composed of a high-grade
metallic alloy that allowed Stark to
remain impervious to medium caliber
weapons like assault rifles and rockets
but also contained flamethrowers on each
arm and a single missile in addition to
this this suit was powered by a small
electrical motor on the back which also
housed a single rocket allowing for jet
propulsion over a limited distance now
for the mark ii after returning from
captivity by the ten rings organization
which had kidnapped stark at the request
of Obadiah Stane tony began making the
mark to armor under the mindset of
transforming stark industries into a
peacekeeping organization as a result
many of the modern designs we see in the
current Iron Man armors stem for the
mark too however the technology found
within was both a streamlined version of
the mark 1 but was also designed
explicitly for this suit and could not
be found anywhere else in the Stark
Industries proper in terms of his
abilities because the suit was a step up
from the mark 1 the mark 2 had flight
thrusters and advanced control flaps
from a new virility but also had
repulsors which were limited to the
palms now unlike the comics which used a
particle beam similar to the exotic
energies of cyclopses optic beams the
repulsors in the Marvel movies
functioned by creating a column of
highly compressed superheated air which
created the same impact as a bullet or
similar projectile however because of
the limits of physics regarding
resistance in friction the radius of the
repulsors was limited to 10 meters or 32
feet a standard which would remain
within all future models furthermore the
suit was capable of communication with
Starks AI program Jarvis via the helmet
and enhance the strength of Tony Stark
however because the mark 2 had frozen
solid after reaching 85,000 feet this
suit was used as a template for both a
mark 3 as well as the war machine armor
worn by James Rhodes now regarded the
mark 3 while this is an updated version
of the mark 2 there were several
features that distinguish the two models
differentiating itself for the marks 1 &
2 by adopting a red and goto color
scheme the whole of the suit was
transitioned away from a metal alloy and
instead use a titanium alloy owing to
the fact the titanium does not freeze
and is resistant to corrosion and
seawater in addition to this the mark 3
used a new miniaturize weapon system
that was concealed in the suits exterior
plating and was able to withstand most
conventional weapons while augmenting
starch physical capabilities with
enhanced speed strength and movements in
terms of its weapon systems the suit
maintained the standard load out of
repulsors from the mark 2 but also
included many guns concealed within the
shoulders I could fire a total of 12
shots
a computer-guided system that allowed
Stark to shoot multiple targets at once
as well as a set of high-explosive
missiles in the forearm each capable of
destroying a full sized tank finally the
mark 3 contained two disc launchers on
the hips that could serve to distract
heat-seeking missiles in addition to
being the first model to fire a single
beam of concentrated energy from the arc
reactor in the chest now because marks 1
2 & 3 were created and used during the
events of Ironman 1 between the
conclusion of the film and the start of
Iron Man 2 Tony Stark developed the mark
4 after the mark 3 was heavily damaged
in the battle with Obadiah Stane at the
end of Iron Man 1 however for all
intents and purposes the improvements to
the mark 4 were cosmetic only and that
the weapons communications and armor
systems of the suit all remain the same
as a result the only real
differentiation between the mark 3 NMR 4
was that the mark 4 possess an improved
design for the metal plating at the
joist allowing for it to be taken on and
off easier now we go to the mark 5 this
suit is the most portable of the Iron
Man armors with most casual fans
referring to it simply as the suitcase
armor debuting during the Monaco
incident involving the first appearance
of whiplash the suit maintaining the
standard load
of March 2 through 4 including repulsor
beams the unibeam but lack the various
shoulder based mini guns missiles and
heavy-duty armor found in the mark 3
however because the suit was designed to
be readily available in emergency
situations the lack of these arms at
armament meant that the armor was much
lighter allow a Stark to deal with
emergency situations and vacate almost
immediately transitioning to the March 6
this suit was created after Tony Stark
formed a new element using information
provided for mr. C's father using the
new element to both power the armor as
well as eliminate the cancer-causing
palladium poisoning within his body the
mark 5 was designed to be several steps
ahead of both the war machine armor worn
by James Rhodes and the various models
designed by whiplash as it was created
because a suit was the first to feature
the new element the abilities of the
mark 5 pushed the strength reflexes and
speed of Stark to higher levels as well
as creating more intense repulsors and
euna beams in addition to granting
improved mobility during flight in terms
of his weapon systems the mark six
contained anti-tank missiles in each arm
a minigun on micro munition that can be
fired and embedded to a surface before
exploding ballistic and explosive
projectiles as well as one use particle
lasers capable of cutting through any
and all materials with the exception of
vibranium moving on to the March 7 this
suit was first revealed in the Avengers
following the March 6 destruction during
the attack on the shield Helicarrier by
the forces of Loki under the control of
Hawkeye while the suits design was
actually incomplete in his debut the
armor was used by Stark after he was
thrown from a window by Loki now in
appearance the arc reactor had returned
to the round form of the previous models
and when not in use this suit exists in
a pod shaped form with a chest plate on
top and the thruster boots on the bottom
furthermore while the armor can only be
activated and worn so long as stalkers
wearing the activation bracelets this
suit provides a standard array of
enhanced flight reflexes speed and
durability but also adds an additional
pair of thrusters from the back giving
the suit improved acceleration and
overall speed in addition to this the
Mach 7 also possesses miniature
air-to-air missiles in each shoulder as
well as anti-tank missiles in each
gauntlet and the same variant of flare
launcher seen in the mark 3 new to the
March sevens arsenal were the lasers in
each wrist drawing power directly from
the arc react
and consisted of three beans a large
central beam and two flaking beams to
enhance the attack however the suit was
considered destroyed and decommissioned
following the nuclear explosion at the
end of the Avengers film and the ensuing
electromagnetic pulse which wiped out
both the Chitauri Army's communications
with its mothership and the suit itself
transitioning to Marx eight nine and ten
in the time following the Battle of New
York and the recognition of threats too
big for the Avengers to handle on their
own start began developing a multitude
of different suits designed to deal with
the various threats on earth taking the
form of drones referred to as the iron
Legion March 8 9 and 10 existed as the
first three models within the first
generation while information is scant on
their capabilities because the models
were present epic inclusion of Iron Man
3 going into the battle with Eldridge
Killian the powers displayed by the
first generation iron Legion suits
ranged from the mark 8 which contain the
standard load out of repulsors a
uni-beam shoulder-mounted missiles and
lasers to the mark 10 which included the
same thing as the mark 8 but also
possessed extra repulsor beams on the
abdomen and a back thruster for improved
speed and flight with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and let me know how you guys feel
about running overall the Iron Man
armors from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I'm kind of curious I
personally think they're pretty cool now
we'll catch you guys later peace